[Music]
two
that's right
i think you do it damn it
wait what did people think you were
saying they thought you were saying
let's go let's ride oh that's right
that's what they thought i was saying i
was saying that's right because it is
right brother that's right we're back
we are back it's the leftovers i hope
that you guys disrupted and destroyed
your thanksgiving dinner on our advice
how was your thanksgiving you don't have
any conservatives in your family i do
not i do not have any conservatives in
my family because they're all they're
all immigrants so they're just like
they're chill
um yeah i think he was was great you
know they uh my whole family came over
to my place
and enough room for everyone there yeah
there's enough room in the in the seven
dollar
mansion just making sure you know
i know i'm spending a lot of money on
that place yeah we still
we don't even have uh i don't even have
like
table space yet so we just you know we
we made it work though you have table
space well i haven't i haven't bought
like a bunch of stuff you've been there
long enough i know i just haven't
because i
i tell people this all the time and they
don't believe me but it's like for me
all i need is just
a
area where i can stream that's in a bed
right and that's literally what has
been the furnishings of my house for
like i think you need a table as well
not really i mean i have a table on my
streaming setup okay you know so where
did you guys eat
we had those like two we had those like
tables that you can open up yeah and we
just put two of those together okay and
then you just
toss a
you know thing on top of it little uh i
don't know what it's called tablecloth
yeah a little tablecloth i mean you
cover you cover
you cover a plastic table with a
tablecloth that thing is slapping that's
what i'm saying yeah it works it like it
literally looks like a fancy table yeah
all of a sudden yeah tablecloths make
this is adult
oh it's true you could put tablecloth
over like cardboard boxes and that [ __ ]
slap yeah all of a sudden you're like
whoa this is a fancy table we don't know
there's a tablecloth on it we don't know
what's going on it could be mahogany
yeah could be cardboard
yeah so that's what i did and it was
great but i i have uh i have a two
cousins
that are both babies i mean they're like
11 and
an 8 or something i forget i'm such a
bad cousin i'm just like a bad relative
but
okay i absolutely destroyed them in like
boomerang foo all the baby games like
mario kart oh hell just
crushed them no mercy they come at you
with confidence or were you
no they're still liking the baby they
weren't even looking for trouble you
just brought yeah no they're they're
they're like now entering the cool zone
because like before that they were like
they were just no content i i would just
be like all right i'm trying to talk to
you but like you're still awkward trying
to talk to them about like uh socialism
no no no
no but like i want to know like what are
they watching you know what i mean like
what are they watching on youtube is it
like still and they were in the baby
shark paw patrol oh really area
but they're no longer there anymore
now they watch they're mister beasts
they'd love mr beast oh my god
wow that's interesting mr bc spans such
an age range
age range dude babies love mr b
they lose their i
i went to yeah literally that's a that's
a baby reacting to the latest mr beast
video
he's like upset that he couldn't be a
part of the squid games what did you
think of the school games people were
criticizing the beast a lot for it i'm
the beast
he's just the beast now to me he is
that's his formal name yeah formerly
known as mysteries now the beast yeah um
what did i think about it i mean
it's it's
mr bees rose to prominence by basically
doing guantanamo bay style torture to
himself
right like literally just like re
watching
its everyday bro for like 12 hours i
think that's literally a violation of
the geneva i think it was like five days
yeah i think it was and that so i i do
have a lot of respect for him for that
but like
that stuff is also like very um
like
trendy
definitely
oh
oh here
watch wait how long is it oh 10 hours 10
hours yeah oh but it does feel like 5
days
10 hours straight i could do that yeah
you could not do that
but it was his idea he did it first
i think what at the time that there was
a 10 hour limit to youtube videos yeah
now you could go forever
yeah and i'd like to see him return to
his humble beginnings frankly yeah you
want you want him to be in this good
game i want a 50-hour
every day bro he does stuff like i mean
now they do like you know corny stuff
like that
did you feel like it's fake prison the
criticism from like people on the left
was basically that he missed the point
and uh
that he shouldn't be recreating
you know well because people are babies
and they think that like
like movies are real
it's very weird people got mad at me
when i did the offline tv squid games
one two oh really yeah and uh i donated
like the earnings uh from that like i
won it spoiler alert sorry oh i didn't
wait but it's gonna watch now i at the
end of it i i conceded to pokemane
simp and
and
basically people were like oh this is
i cannot believe that a movie about you
know proletarian violence is being
depicted by a bunch of millionaire
youtubers i'm like you know that's not
real right it's also like just a game
you don't actually have slaves yeah
they're like literal baby games being
recreated by people for youtube yeah the
criticism of him was kind of wild
because like
i think people just try too hard they do
too much it's like he's just having fun
he donated a bunch of money i mean
mr beast is a good guy there's no reason
to
um yeah he i it was
some people were upset because it's like
it's so bottom of the barrel but it's
like but it's youtube okay yeah and the
other guy there was one big tweet that
was like and like what we do isn't
yeah no i i agree what i do is literally
a you know boneless version of what cnn
does i guess but so much better rest in
peace cuomo
yeah
yeah rest in peace cuomo bro
well he's coming back on january is that
confirmed that's what i saw i don't know
i don't think anyone wants him back i
can't have no shots they'll bring him
back i do it with everyone they'll
they'll bring him back he's there he's
the sexy himbo like he he's the let's
get after it first of all he's he's a
he's a person of color as an attacker
he's italian yes
yeah he's a poc and also on top of that
he's uh he's got himbo representation
going for him he is definitely him both
status this story is crazy a lot of a
lot of media did not cover this yeah so
just to give people context his brother
you know many of you probably know some
of you don't his brothers was the
governor
of the state of new york andrew cuomo
rose to grip damn he is yeah
okay dude are you gonna be
kidding
[Laughter]
dude what a yakked ass no limit baby yes
so anyway his brother the governor
andrew cuomo
who rose to great prominence during the
pandemic height of the pandemic for
doing these briefings and people saw him
you want a as this
of me and he wrote a book and like you
know old people were dying in all folk
songs yeah he was writing a book about
how great his achievements were wow old
people were just straight up like
coveted was brutalizing i've i've always
been super anti andrew cuomo like really
yeah you saw it from the beginning what
was your well anyway just to finish well
the main the main thing i was gonna say
is because he literally gutted medicaid
in the state he's super right wing like
he's a super right-wing
a democrat he's an establishment
democrat so anyway everybody loved him
during the pandemic his ratings were way
up people thought he was going to be
president but a huge well there was like
two huge scandals that broke about him
in the wake of this one was about uh
sexual harassment of his employees
and which was bad enough it was very bad
and then the second one was that he was
hiding the number of elderly deaths
in
in uh care homes
and basically he had to resign in
disgrace
and now it came out that his brother who
works for cnn
was um
using his connections at cnn to find out
who his anonymous
accusers were during the sexual
harassment yeah that's [ __ ] insane
yeah if he was just like giving him
advice that's one thing because i when i
saw that originally i was like well it's
his brother you know but then i found
out the extra details i was like okay
that's i didn't read the all the
specific details like what what is it
that he did
he was like
basically hounding his sources for extra
information on like accusers and their
background
that's something appropriate bro yeah
you know not you can't do that yeah um i
also love uh liz smith pete boudeja just
comms director oh yeah that was good she
was uh
she was in the background
like [ __ ] on dr christine blasey
ford brett kavanaugh's accuser while
pete buddha judge was tweeting about how
like i still stand with dr christine
blasey ford like these people are all
demons okay they don't actually care
about justice they don't actually care
about any of the causes that they
espouse like i hate to say this but
because the right wing is comprised of
demons for sure right especially the
politicians the operatives they're crazy
they're vultures they're parasitic
but
their
their criticism
of like
liberal operatives
is honestly true like
behind closed doors these people do not
give a [ __ ] they just straight up
use like your sexes your races to
attack
members of the left regularly bernie
sanders being the most prominent one um
isaac dover of the atlantic was uh was
literally writing pro andrew cuomo
articles
because he was
he had constant back and forth
correspondence with liz smith isaac
dover famously also was incredibly
anti-bernie and wrote many articles
about how bernie is also sexist and
racist and yadda yadda so these guys are
they're they're doing hatchet jobs
regularly
that's right establishment democrats
yeah they they'll weaponize it yeah
i know the establishment will pretty
much do anything to do you legitimize
bernie yeah by the way today's episode
is sponsored by raycon
i forgot to say that oh i've got to say
that it's off for the show anyway back
to uh special harassment yeah
this uh anyway um
yeah the thing on the right does though
now with the cuomo story that's like
just
so [ __ ] s
obvious and horrible is like the
liberals don't even care that about this
story about cuomo and it's like everyone
is literally tap dancing on this dude's
grave nobody is sad
everybody's talking about it i see more
liberals talking about these cuomo
brothers taking the l
than anything but okay so what eat [ __ ]
the funniest part about it is when
republicans are like andrew cuomo hit
nursing home deaths and it's like
dude you live in florida yeah you care
about cuomo you care about kova deaths
all of a sudden it's not even just that
like your governor ron death santos
literally sent like
gestapo ass cops to like a
whistleblower's house and like terrified
their [ __ ] child with guns at
gunpoint because like one right i
remember that over data
input people uh had the audacity to
reveal the truth about what andrew
desantis was doing yeah
anyway play this dan you got something
here good for us tucker calls him
praises chris cuomo yeah i was gonna say
now now
now that he's getting thrown under the
bus
are you [ __ ] kidding me yep so yes we
did make fun of chris cuomo quite a bit
on this show in fact pretty relentlessly
for the past five years chris cuomo was
a buffoon
he was also in the way that buffoons
tend to be incredibly self-righteous and
false
here he is
self-imposed quarantine in his basement
after recovering from covid
we had a huge day today in casa cuomo
take a look at this
all right here is the official
re-entry from the basement
cleared by cdc a little sweaty just
worked out
this is what i've been dreaming this is
odd literally for weeks this
is the dream just to be back up here
doing normal things
oh his poor family he pulled them into
it
we learned later the whole thing was
fake chris cuomo hadn't quarantined in
fact he'd been out and about wandering
around long island without a mask
yelling at anyone who questioned him is
that true no one else at the time
was he really cruising around i think
there was i think he was like jogging or
something he was jogging while he i
don't remember the exact details right
dan do you have intel on that uh i could
look into it i don't know actually but i
wouldn't be surprised then i mean
[ __ ] throw him in the damn pit
um
i remember uh
by the way again hilarious that like
tucker garlson is upset at chris cuomo
for this it just came out recently that
donald trump tried to
assassinate joe biden oh yeah during oh
like they know for sure he has he had um
yeah he knew he had covert and like they
just straight up were like no we're
going to the debates and he's like
goading joe biden like oh you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you you're trying to like get that
over to him yeah come on shake my hand
[ __ ] yeah come on
he was he he was willing to like he
would have been he died for it i think
he would have been very happy about that
oh yeah i mean joe biden no shot he
survives covered he can't right
he's i don't know i don't even know how
he survives a light breeze you know he
would die come on man so uh the only
thing i could find about uh cuomo
jogging
it it's maybe a stretch it's not like he
was in the city it looks like he's
like he still shouldn't okay
oh it says he's on recovery wait hold on
let me read this quote chris cuomo was
taking a huge step in kovalev 19
recovering he was returning to bro mode
this is not
this is after this is after no the
actual story is that a man claimed that
chris cuomo yelled at him in the
hamptons i think or something like that
where like there was a there was some
guy who said
uh
i mean you know how these guys are they
just like
i feel like that's [ __ ] you can't if
you're chris cuomo pretending to be in
quarantine you can't just go cruise
around
like enough people know who he is yeah
anyway just go ahead and play it let's
see what this dip [ __ ] has to say
he seemed bothered at all by this but it
struck us as a big deal it was too phony
but his bosses didn't care before you
knew it chris cuomo was back on
television barking at you for yes
not wearing a mask
put on the damn mask if you're in
california if you're in a riverside wear
the map
situations like this where you live wear
the mask
if we care about doing the right things
i wear a mask for you as much as i wear
it for me i had the disease you need to
wear a damn mask and you have to take
care of other people in your community
and it's got to be about us because the
help's not going to come from above
you
okay so here it is guy who's screwed
i found it on april 15 the long island
new york bicyclist filed the police
report after getting into a test
exchange with cuomo in front of the
hamptons home on easter sunday
um
that's what they're tying that into i
don't know how the timeline matches up
but basically like
cuomo's uh there was like a campaign
communication director for the trump
campaign that uh
literally used the fox news host tucker
carlson's
um you know coverage to say
you broke like everyone knows you broke
uh quarantine and cuomo said i did the
wrong thing i never broke oh
and then murtaugh said everyone knows
you broke it and cuomo said he never
broke quarantine
okay whatever not that interesting i
guess yeah whatever
like but get to the part where he tries
to start sucking his name yeah he's
taken he's taken yeah you're taking way
too far he's like listen he's a good guy
but you know if you want to sk if you
want to go into his house and kill him
and his whole family
that's a good idea too
here i'm gonna i'm gonna skip wait wait
wait wait he asked you to wear a mask
people oh that was a sound bite for a
second i thought tucker carlson was
laughing
you like that laugh
it's so creepy it's so slimy
now that's joker brains zack
that's true dr carlson is very joking
all right he's he's not the only one
that wants to suck uh
cuomo's dick now come on get to the act
that's when for the first time ever and
very unexpectedly we started to feel
sorry for chris cuomo
helping his brother is not the worst
thing chris cuomo ever did in fact it
may have been the best thing he ever did
not because andrew cuomo was a good
person he certainly wasn't a good person
andrew coleman was loathsome but andrew
cuomo was chris cuomo's brother
and that's what you do with brothers
you help them when they need it bros
before hope am i right it's called
loyalty
at cnn as at the rest of the media this
is an alien concept
is there a single person at cnn or any
other left-wing network who would risk
his job to help his own brother dude no
okay he did not risk his job he did not
think he was going to get any reward and
dude we're talking about
exposing the identity of anonymous
accusers who are victim of his brother's
sexual harassment this is such a weird
take
like what
right on brand for it's right on
breakfast the one thing he did good was
trying to victimize and belittle the
accusations of uh sex of women that his
brother sexually harassed in fact harvey
weinstein is innocent to this day i say
that and i am i love his films yeah it's
yeah good will hunting is one of my
favorite films i love harvey weinstein
you're just racist against our people
we're not wrong
yeah
that that's right though that's true
it's all italian phobia they never they
would never fire a white man for this
okay wasps they get away with this stuff
regularly yo but like andrew is kind of
a hulking giant compared to his little
he's kind of a little manlet uh chris
how dare you
how dare you manlet rights i'm an
advocate how tall is manlet's cuomo wait
andrew cuomo is only 511. so no [ __ ]
way oh no chris cuomo like actually five
seven five eight i wonder he's so jacked
he's got
he's got a lot of fun you're you're
ruining this for me right now look how
tiny he is he's looking more guilty by
the second
call the police immediately
um
go ahead how tall is chris
what's weird i'm seeing chris listed as
like six one but he's clearly so what's
his brother like seven feet tall well it
says andrew cuomo's five eleven so that
something ain't had enough here
that [ __ ]
if he's five eleven your boy chris cuomo
is like four nine
he was he was making efforts to track
down the status of pending articles at
other news outlets before they were
released so he could like give that
information to his crisis management he
did a good job
tucker's like he did a good job with
that one yeah yeah i like that dude
everywhere is listing chris cuomo as
being like 6-2 that's impossible
this is fake [ __ ] news
okay that makes more sense i want to
believe he's sick his brother's hulking
above him yeah keep the dream alive baby
look look at that one of the top left
you can see their whole bodies
that guy has like [ __ ] three inches
on how tall is andrew cuomo it says 511
i mean maybe that's not accurate somehow
his taller brother's 511 and chris is
6-2 yeah that doesn't make sense yeah
that lit that does not make sense
this is height gate we need to do a
whole segment of boxes like this though
like first of all a lot of politicians
are super tall so i wouldn't be
surprised if andrew cuomo was taller
than 511 and it says his 511. i think my
height is wrong on on google too it says
i'm 6'3 but i'm 6'4 so you know things
oh poor you
yeah yeah exactly how are you bro i'm
the real victim here
really is it does say six three
look how little he looks
okay who cares sorry short game this is
i care this is the real rule of the
world
all right let's move on [ __ ] the cuomo
brothers
yeah
yeah and guys if you can correct the
sun's height that's probably the biggest
injustice going on apparently in this
country you need to know are you really
six four do we need to get out the tape
measurement we can if you want are you
like six three and a half
are you like over six four a little bit
like what are we i don't know what like
the change is but no i'm six four okay
unless i got shorter and like unless i
hit 30 and i started you know shriveling
like an old person i don't think that
starts to happen yet no i don't think so
either
zach is 6'3 zach come over here zach is
6'3
unless zach's been lying yeah i mean do
we really know that
come here for sure next to hassan he's
all over it he's
he's
all right guys stand up here this is
this is the height broadcast now all
right and let's take off our well you
guys have the same shoes on actually
yeah yeah all right so
okay actually you know what zach
yeah i actually think zach's lying about
his height
because
hassan has like two inches on you bro
he's like significantly taller than you
scroll up you can't see their domes
here i'll take mine wait hold on
you got to see that you got to see
they're done a little bit
maybe put it up yeah
yeah so hassan is significantly taller
than you zach
but i think you i think you might be six
too i hate to tell you
oh [ __ ] dude everything is too short on
me it's not good people never think
about the people never think about the
plight of big boys they just don't they
really don't
i don't know that you're a big boy zach
she's definitely big
i think zach might be a normal boy
in the big boy club thank you i can see
i got the approval no he's he's it's not
his approval to get his approval no of
course it is it's like you want it you
want to be a big boy zach you like we
see
you look like a tiny person next to the
sun you look that doesn't count you look
like you look like chris cuomo next to
andrew cuomo
well my height says i'm taller than his
son on the internet
all right there you go the internet's
not true always thank you zach yeah all
right i'm glad that we addressed four
yeah i give it up
you might be six five no
short kings like with shoes maybe but no
well what a world i don't even know i
haven't what a world like i feel like
after a certain point you never measured
that you know i mean i i have not
measured my height it
could be taller i could be shorter i
don't know what a world last time i went
to the doctor it said i was three that's
what i'm going by mm-hmm
[Music]
were you wearing shoes when they took
that i like to see that in writing yeah
what kind of shoes are you wearing i was
wearing vans i was wearing flat
shoes
we're gonna have to talk about this on
on after dark we're gonna take this
conversation we're going to take bus
stop the tape measurement on zach
all right
six dude then are you going to be like a
song's lion 363. no you look like you
got two inches on him bro
maybe we got to call zach out all right
let's move on hold him accountable yeah
we got to hold our people accountable
um you guys are both tall [ __ ] you you
know what i mean it's like nobody care
nobody's sad for you guys being oh one
inch less not as tall see this is what i
mean nobody cares about us tall boys
yeah and they showed it
it's messed up it's [ __ ] up being paul
is some [ __ ] it's like some [ __ ]
siding with ryan kavanagh that's it
[Laughter]
oh you [ __ ] how tall is he let me
brian kavanaugh's a manlet let me see
how you you don't want to be on his you
don't want to be on his team right
kavanagh height oh well nobody cares
about it it says 511 he ain't 5 11. we
got to find him standing next to
somebody
famous whose height is really accurate
yeah exactly what's harvey weinstein's
height there's lots of pictures of them
together
good question carving weinstein oh so
harvey weinstein was apparently six foot
okay so if you could so if you google
harvey
weinstein ryan kavanagh this is a really
good experiment
because there there is a lot of images
of them standing next to each other
yeah
actually you know what it looks like
harvey weinstein that's what
that's what i've been saying bro we made
a whole website dedicated to that so
maybe he's not that short
do you see it
wait that's what i've been saying bro
if you if you google ryan kavanagh
you'll probably find on that does ryan
kavanaugh look like harvey weinstein.com
what the [ __ ] you know that's my website
right
it's so stupid
we made that website to help the public
[Laughter]
it's uh now on the front page
no this is the
this is to help people like you
this is a public service
oh my god
this is good for ryan because people you
know who are casually yeah yeah and so
like if you go down the public is
confused oh my god like okay dude the
slider oh no you see the resemblance
dude the slider makes it so much worse
the slider straight up is like it's the
same person but ginger exactly that's
what i'm saying so it's important no you
see the importance of this website
okay and then there's we also made a
game
to test yourself
so the public's opinion ethan klein
alarming something has to be done which
is why i made the website here tell me
if you played the game and tell me so
here check this out three two one begin
okay harvey orion
uh harvey weinstein
nope you're wrong no
you wanna try again okay harvey or ryan
ryan kavanagh
see you're wrong no
hard okay
all right i'm gonna get this one i'm
gonna get this one i'm gonna get this
one
ryan cavanaugh
you're wrong that's three
you see what i'm saying though it's hard
it's hard so that's why we made the
website uh hell
did you really not know that was our
website no that's so awesome yeah no we
made that i don't know anything about i
don't know anything about ryan kavanagh
like i just i saw that he was you know
suing you or something yeah like
that's about it that's all there is to
it but yeah so
so oh my god is he kissing harvey
weinstein yeah exactly that's what i'm
saying there's a picture of him kissing
okay well well it's like you know it's
like it's like
batman and clark i mean uh superman and
clark kent like they have been in the
same room together so you know oh that's
the only way you know they're not the
same person yeah look at this look at
that big old kiss for his idol
he could have been a saddam style body
double by the way though since we're on
the topic i'm just saying
can we show can you pull up that tweet
we found of him and he's defending
harvey right as the metoo stuff comes
out it's pretty no and it's still up as
well it's still up yeah he doesn't know
that we found it that's why we already
cataloged it send me the tweet uh link
dance you can just show it
yeah watch what he said about his bro
his good friend
okay he definitely is a body double for
him though you think he's a body double
well well harvey's in jail and now ryan
is very okay so wait send me the okay
and this is still up send me the link
just so
we can
this is in august 2000's joe blase says
with respect at ryan kavanagh with
respect do you consider harvey and bob
weinstein films friends of yours
and ryan cavanaugh says brilliant
creative minds never underestimate
harvey he is a survivor yeah
there's there it is still up that's
crazy what's the survivor we got i gotta
get back to the end if you like it he's
eating that for sure yeah maybe i should
well it's yeah well i mean after that it
had one like so what did the quote
tweets say can you click those
well it looks like people found it
because look there's a bunch of people
uh replying within the last hour great
minds think and look alike
that's true
that's true
click quote tweets uh
let's see bruh bruh
many people don't know this this is a
interesting fact but harvey weinstein
has uh no penis
that's not even a joke what does that
mean he uh i forget what kind of
he's a micro penis no no no no no he has
like an issue so his penis is like
mangled like a leopard penis
like
like yeah excuse me google it right now
wait so
that's super interesting i always wonder
about the harvey weinstein stuff because
his thing was always he would like
pressure women into sexual acts and
never
he would never want them to like
participate willingly he has a deformed
penis yeah super interesting yeah that
people i mean people that were doing
arms arbitrary psychology or even not
even people who are doing aren't trans
psychology but like they believe that
this contributed to his like uh
sexual pathology and the way that he
wanted to like dominate women
uh because he just could not like use
his oh that's whatever harvey weinstein
suffers from an acute infection that
contributed to his deformed penis
according to a recent report it was
revealed in court
deformed genitalia is the result of a
life-threatening bacterial infection
known as
fournier's
gangrene holy [ __ ] he had gangrene in
his dick yeah that that just happens to
evil
yeah if you get gangrene in your dick
that's like that's what happens when
like you make a deal with the devil yeah
that's why when people say like
oh we should like neuter people or
whatever we should neuter rapists or
whatever it's like no that doesn't that
don't don't stop them oh yeah yeah you
know
the def uh the deformity was first
revealed in court when actress jessica
mann one of harvin's harvey weinstein's
accusers said she left
feeling compassionate for him after she
saw his deformed genitals
yeah
whoa
that's low-key like the probably the
worst thing you could do to harvey
weinstein too because like saying like
oh man oh that sucks like
all of a sudden you're no longer not to
say that this is the way to deal with it
obviously but i'm saying that like
if you think about the psychology behind
it you think about like what motivates
his actions obviously he's like a purely
evil person
but
the reason why he's engaging in these
actions he's so angry because he cares
more about power and dominating the
other person and that's the only way he
can get off but you know what's
interesting is that
when you read of all the accusations it
was always like coerced sexual activity
like he would go in the shower and make
him watch watch them shower and you're
like well you know he's like physically
disgusting
yeah nobody wants to look at him or get
turned on from but now knowing he had to
deform penis you can only imagine that
the only reaction and he knew it was was
just disgust yeah and horror and he
liked that you know you get that crotch
rot
yeah like the quartering
yeah it's wild all right guys thank you
uh for watching that's the whole show
i'm just kidding it's a commercial break
uh i don't know what's the jail
we'll be right back oh time to take a
short break
thank you thank you to raycon by now
you've probably seen about a thousand
gift guides for the holiday season gifts
for mom gifts for guides gifts for your
neighbor's cousin's dog
is it this
dogs can use them
well i don't think they're talk we're
not talking about raycons yet
oh oh my bad sorry could they use them i
don't know
uh you could study all those games you
could benefit from the best the bass
boosting right i think dogs like bass
yeah
at least my cool off dogs do you could
study all those gift guides and shop at
10 different places or you could just
start shopping at raycon and get a gift
everyone is going to love raycon
wireless earbuds i love these earbuds
they're comfortable they're slick
they've got all these uh music settings
which is really great they've got a pure
mode a balance mode a base mode
and
i'll be honest it's just as good as all
these like super expensive name brands
that you know about
it's half the price
it's just that simple folks raycon gives
you that amazing audio quality of
wherever you go whether you use them to
exercise wind down work work out pump up
they're useful for anyone on the list
and even better for you they start at
half the price
as other premium auto brands and with
their latest model you get three sound
profiles to make everything you're
listening to sound just as good as it
should i already mentioned those pure
mode balance mode base mode raycon is
available in five stylish colors so you
can pick a perfect one for everyone on
your list and with free shipping and
returns gift giving is easier than it
has ever been
the holidays are coming up faster than
you think now is the time to knock out
that gift list and avoid the last minute
shipping scramble especially because
right now my listeners will get 15 off
site wide with the code holiday at
byraycon.com
leftovers go to buy raycon.com
leftovers and use the code holiday
to get fifteen percent off your entire
raikon order byraycon.com
leftovers thank you thank you
all right let's get to some stuff here
uh
we we covered some really important
we've been covering good ground i've
learned so much today it's true okay
you know i i wanted to
give the gift of knowledge back to you a
little bit about harvey weinstein's
penis actually it is actually obviously
don't know if ryan looks the part at all
saying that they do so the thing is that
ryan kavanagh and harvey weinstein have
a physical resemblance you would assume
i would not say that that part
i cannot deal with a lawsuit okay please
i'm saying that okay yeah
and the public is confused yeah maybe
not you i still want to know like you
already said it by the way yeah you
already know i did not you literally
said he kind of looks like harvey
weinstein okay wait you can't sue
someone for that i do uh he is suing me
for that he says it's defamation in one
of his lawsuits he literally said i
defamed him by saying he looks like
harvey weinstein what's really [ __ ] up
is when you went back in time and
convinced him to tweet that in 2016
august of 2016 though yeah like his
defense of his uh body double allegedly
body double we don't know if we don't
know if there was a contractual
obligation to appear as body as a body
for harvey weinstein but it's true
nobody forced him to publicly defend
harvey and call him a survivor yeah he
is just well he is alive still so thank
you very important choice of words
very poor yeah i think that's deliberate
when you he's the real survivor like not
the [ __ ] victims so gross
love that love that about him yeah
you want to talk about jordan peterson
uh he's selling a bust of his head do i
a mom this is this is awesome and you
know i've kind of just basically been on
a bit of a jordan peterson kick lately
he said he tweeted this out free
shipping and it's just
like a bust of his dome uh all glory to
the great lobster god or whatever
and what's interesting is that
oh you can get it in bronze oh you get
in bronze too
how much is the bronze one don't
purchase the bronze one because
obviously you know i'm white
and the bronze one actually is
inappropriate
my skin color is not accurate
men
um
what's interesting is that if he's being
sold among other great
men like napoleon bonaparte
frederick neat that is not how hot
napoleon yeah i was like what the [ __ ]
you didn't look like him that's [ __ ]
well the makers are french so there is
there of course of course yeah uh
frederick nietzsche they all look kind
of
he was the best looking man
this i believe is poseidon
um i don't know who the [ __ ] that is
dostoyevsky
uh yeah i grew up in turkey so i'm very
familiar with marcus aurelius
unfortunately
chopin and then of course
jordan peterson
yeah a famous french uh thinker
i mean it's just bizarre first of all
it's 360 bucks
and he is promoting it
and i just find it so what like so vain
like bro you should not be authorizing
people to sell this
where would we be without bus he's
giving glory to me also he does not look
like that
i mean yeah i'm not that bad at all it's
it's a pretty decent i'm not going to
create that yeah it's a pretty decent
recreation
um you know it looks like a face you
know in the haunted mansion what's up is
jordan peterson over six foot is that
why you're [ __ ] on his bus is that
what's going on he is tall do i have to
defend him now
i think this is an accurate depiction
dan what are you pulling this up for
first of all that's a weird photo you
don't know what you're trying to prove
i just google jordan peterson is the
third photo on it it's the deep fried
yeah what the [ __ ] he's doing he's on an
anti he's on an auntie jordan peterson
kick here yeah be fair your criticism
dan okay let me find a better picture
because he's a he's a dirty little tall
do you hate addicts is that why wow
wow i didn't say that
or do you hate recovering addicts bro
that's [ __ ]
well where would we be
he's about to tweet it then like
come over here and say that to my face
and i'll show you
what the benzos buckle yeah what was
that he recently started threatening
people on uh i'll [ __ ] you in the ass
buddy until you love me yeah he's
come over here
threatening himself yeah it's it's
always funny though because he's such a
frail ass like he one he's canadian
sorry like most canadians are
automatically they're just like even if
they're jacked come say that to my face
and we'll see who needs a benzel buckle
when i first saw that i was like this
has to be photoshopped i've retweeted it
it's so good
i just i love
i i love that he's just like he's the
guy who who cries thinking about like
the uh destruction of western
civilization by you know a gay marxist
or whatever but then he's also like i'll
beat your ass bucko it's like no you
won't you're like
70 years old and you almost died
drinking apple cider like
yeah what did what i got to do in
defense
[ __ ] glass of apple cider throw it in
his spiral back yeah you spiral back
i'll [ __ ] throw apple cider in your
face you'll melt like the villain from
bugs bunny
nor roger rabbit
remember at the end of roger rabbit i've
never seen it but anyone got that yeah
no i got your reference christopher
lloyd
oh was christopher light yeah yeah yeah
well anyways if you guys
yeah
that's
the irony with the books on the ground
which i always also have is is it like
his room has never been cleaned it's
always been a [ __ ] mess
yeah never been clean
i just well anyway this could be yours
for 360 bucks i was wondering if we
should buy one just uh what do you i
mean
i'll get one i'm going to do a
contribute though you can't oh
where would we be without men we need
more semen on my bust
yeah come on over here hassan and give
me your load okay i've said i jokingly
said that but you know like people that
buy that are someone's gonna do that
oh for sure and now that you've got that
fan no no no not even before i set out
just out of pure love and adoration 100
percent
also like weirdo in cells that love him
you know what i mean for the most part i
mean not anymore but
come over here let me see your [ __ ] let
me ask you something here and uh you can
tell me if this is uh
you know something that you don't want
to talk about or elaborate but you've
had jordan peterson on twice yeah yeah
back when you used to be
a little bit closer to the center center
right i would say from my point of view
um i wouldn't how did you no no on
certain issues but how did you
how did you feel like did you what was
it that was so captivating about him
okay so first of all when we first um
invited jordan i wasn't super familiar
with him i just saw kind of the
phenomenon around him yeah and he is a
doctor he's a psychologist of some
renown
and um i was like well you know i seen
him on other shows
and i thought
uh and then someone was like hey you
should have this guy on and i was like
okay you know i was inviting everyone on
at the time
and so he was on and we didn't talk
about politics or anything we talked
about like psychology and [ __ ] like that
so i found it really interesting just
you know
um i thought the conversation was great
it was a really interesting conversation
i didn't know anything about his
politics on like
he's obviously transphobic you know and
um
yeah he has all kinds of
well we've covered like for example
recently on the podcast you know i know
i know i know your current position on
him i'm just saying like no i thought he
was very interesting from a clinical
standpoint he's really articulate he's
he sounds good
um he's really he can grapple with
complex like ideas that we talked about
and it was a really great captivating
conversation everybody loved it you know
i got a show do you look at the discord
is that a real photo that's a real photo
oh so he is a roger rabbit that's that's
from um that's like old jordan peterson
like i feel like he's always been kind
of like he's an incel yeah for sure i
can hit my fedora lady
tip tip tip got a feather in my cap in
your honor i have the most reddit karma
out of anyone here
if only you knew how much reddit karma i
had you'd be on your knees sucking my
dick right now
i remember when we had him on it was
very early into me working for you ethan
and i didn't know anything about him at
all when he came on and i too uh you
know for the first probably hour hour
and a half of the episode that he was on
did he save you dan
well i just you know i was a lost man he
was talking he was mostly just talking
about self-help actualization that kind
of stuff and you know
that's not really my jam but i could see
why people found him interesting he's
very articulate and everything i
remember it was about an hour and a half
in though when he started
he he mentioned
cultural marxism for the first time and
that was like the moment where i raised
an eyebrow like what i still don't know
what that means cultural marxism is
literally the exact same modernized
propaganda version of what nazis say
about cultural bolshevistmas which is
i've been like ever since you said that
word i was like i've been trying to be
like what is that it's literally the
republican modern day conservative
equivalent to frankfurt school jews
control the media
and and academia
and uh you know
that he's not i'll say in his defense he
is not anti-semitic i've heard him no no
i don't think so either yeah i think
he's just a regular conservative and
there's a lot of people who are regular
conservatives who are repeating
um
who who are repeating basically
watered-down like fascist talking points
that doesn't mean that they themselves
are like ideologically uh fascist or
anything like they're not [ __ ]
reading like culture of critique and
being like yeah this is real
it's more so that they're repeating
talking points because it makes sense to
them and it's instead of like
jews the
cultural marxism is just marxists like
whoever is in academia socialist
marxists that are like you know
um that are that are leading to the
degeneracy of the west the western
civilization that is supreme it's now
falling apart because of
feminism women in the workplace
uh gay uh gay people and trans people
being able to like co-exist openly in
society uh immigration
all of this stuff is is a product of
cultural marxism is what nazis used to
say they would say it's cultural
bolshevism now regular conservatives
just say cultural minds i still don't
know what cultural marxism means like
you know what i mean like i understand
what they're trying to say but to this
day it's like jordan peterson's a man
for the masses right like the common man
they love him red pill whatever
like
his plebian
he's talking to these
men who are not in my problem i'm just
assuming not super well read on all
these complex political ideas don't
worry neither is he well he keeps saying
these big work grandiose words like
cultural marxism and i still don't
[ __ ] know like what is it cultural
okay we're talking about the culture
marxism which is like you know communism
right it's the idea that academics uh
that have a ideological predisposition
towards like marxism
or whatever conservatives consider to be
marxism are
basically infiltrating all of our
colleges all of our institutions and
dictating culture
and trying to
uh trying to you know create the next
generation of marxist by brainwashing
that's interesting because he never
explicitly defines it like that but if
that so like he's his theory that's why
he got owned by [ __ ] dumpster diving
raccoon slavok
like he said that and jordan peterson
was like oh i don't know i don't know
you know like he had nothing for that
because there aren't that much it's a
fancy buzzword that
now not saying that wikipedia is the
most reputable source but i was actually
surprised to see that their article
about it is literally part of their
series on anti-semitism because it is it
is a modern
modern rendition but it's just like this
okay now
republicans don't say america was
founded on christian values they say
judeo-christian values they just updated
it they tweaked it the in-group now
features uh
jews as well to a certain degree and
that's a conditional relationship that
will and most likely uh you know the
moment that there's any sort of like
serious fascist power grab that will go
away
okay
but it's just they're like yeah we're
welcoming we're welcoming white
hispanics into the in group and we're
welcoming uh jews of the ingroup that's
why they say judeo-christian values now
interesting
well that's the meaning yeah i'm old
light and alt-right is the is the
anti-semitism are you gonna do overt
anti-semitism or are you going to
bake in without maybe even without
recognizing that you're engaging in like
anti-semitic conspiracy theories
somehow the jews are always first to go
you know
yeah
but uh that said his fascination with
the
soviet art is um a weird wrinkle in his
whole thing
i remember he talked about this when he
came on our show too yeah he was like an
avid collector of soviet well the thing
that's real interesting about that hobby
which i actually think is cool is that
he's like if you go on ebay you can find
buy all this like original
soviet art for like next to nothing yeah
i love soviet and it's beautiful
original art so i get that you know it
is really cool
vladimir putin
you know who said that who
do you know
forgot his name it's stephen stephen
oh you put a mega stink on it do it
again zach vladimir putin yeah steven
seagal uh vladimir putin
vladimir putin yeah
yeah he's he's a king he's a god amongst
men
um let's talk about joe rogan now
with his uh gramp his grandpa
instagram [ __ ] posts
yeah this was a weird take by joe if you
need any more evidence he's completely
fallen
here's all you need to see
um uh here he posted this
so on the top you have authoritarian on
the on the right
libertarian on the bottom left so
strongmen would be you know nazis yeah
yeah
that's what he i i
i don't think joe rogan understands the
graph like i don't think he's like hey
hey i'm gonna red pill my audience like
i'm secretly a nazi i think he's a
[ __ ] he's a gorilla and he was just
like oh this is good dude at what at
what point do we stop doing like the
ignorance uh no no he's the impact is is
you know incredible he's not that dumb
like he knows what this says
authoritarian right like he knows what
that means it's [ __ ] nazis well most
people don't know what the [ __ ] the
political compass meme is unless they're
like hyper online and my entire
community is extremely online so and i
am also so when i see this i'm like what
the [ __ ] are you doing you're literally
promoting you're basically saying that
nazis are strong men
and the good times are the libertarian
right wingers which you know a little
too pedophilic for me but you know for
my taste
but uh
maybe that's what they mean by good
times and then it breeds weak men and
then weak men breed hard times is a
super old trope that the alt-right has
routinely used
and this is like a classic nazi meme
there's like a million different uh
versions of this old like 2016 era nazi
memes and he's just like posting them on
his on his instagram
like an old man but
the implication of course being that
anything left is bad it's you've got
weak men and hard times on the left and
on the right you've got good strong men
and good times on the right so
what's he saying here like we're in we
are in kali yuga the age of conflict all
the chaos we're seeing right now is
predicted in hinduism thousands of years
ago civilizations move in predictable
cycles and we're in the lower left-hand
square of the chart
do your best yeah we're in the window
so what he's trying to say is
like first of all joe rogan would be
on the lower left part of that chart
technically i mean what is he actually
doing
you know uh oh
you
what are you doing that's hard right now
what are you doing to be the strong man
right now jeff
he's eating you're being paid hundreds
of millions of dollars by
spotify you're living in your special
little
ranch uh in texas you're literally not
doing anything for the betterment of
society what are you doing that makes
you a strong man other than actually
lifting weights yeah he's lifting
weights so that that means there's a
strong me on the other hand when i lift
weights i'm still a soy boy because i'm
a leftist yeah you know what i mean
that's how it works like it's not that's
why it's just pathetic this whole
masculinity thing he's just he's a
[ __ ] pathetic
[ __ ] [ __ ] i think he's he's been
criticized so much that he's just i
think he's just um
how do i say he's
lost the plot he's definitely lost buzz
but he's kind of just
what's what's the word he's kind of just
retracted back and fallen into the
people that support him and just
surrounding himself with yes men and all
the people and so he's just he's
surrounded by
yeah the people that give him
unconditional support are clout sharks
that want to ride the wave like you know
they they they will do anything and
everything nothing joe rogan says is
ever too far or bad they will change or
even tailor their own point of view for
the most part to agree with joe rogan
right they get rewarded handsomely for
it too because he still does capture a
gigantic audience well the truth is like
and even now to this day you know it's
he is such a gatekeeper to the the
comedy world
um like podcasters specifically who
wanna need to go on there and suck the
teat of his audience that people will
[ __ ] go on that show
and co-sign the [ __ ] now the [ __ ] that
he's saying and promoting
because they have to for his career
their career yeah one thing that i find
uh as an old-school joe rogan head who
used to watch him like way back in the
day before even like he started bringing
on like milo yiannopoulos and all these
right-wingers
was that
he he went through the regular uh uh
pattern of of like becoming more
radicalized like i think it was he was a
big like divorced wife guy
he would always talk about alimony like
he would always talk about a buddy of
mine
that has
never been divorced
he hasn't been yeah a lot of his
finances okay so that was his like angle
into men's right activist a lot of
people get radicalized by divorce court
um
a lot of men do a lot of men um and and
there's probably some truth to that you
know yeah alimony and stuff so
so he would always talk about that but
it was mostly just like dmt moon landing
was fake you know stuff like that
and then he started having and this is
uh you know friend of mine felix
biederman of chapo trap house he he uh
talked about this as well he's like
he just started having media guys on you
know what i mean
and and these guys have coached talking
points they have like clear
interest in like disseminating
misinformation they're the real they're
the real mark uh cultural yeah i
wouldn't say cult they're the fastest
cultural fascists yeah they are the
cultural fashion yeah and they're
getting paid handsomely their agent
promotes the infiltrate
uh to promote this point of view
and then his show is like ever since
there was like waves right
where he really was like hamming on the
the right wing stuff he was he was
basically making the careers of like
literal people who turned out to be
nazis like stefan malnier oh yeah milo
yiannopoulos like he had all these
people on but back then there was only
one point that he had that he would
always be an advocate for and that was
weed right he would actually challenge
people other than that he was a
chameleon
like he always adopted whoever his guest
was and adopted their point of view
except for
weed and in some instances he would push
back on dave rubin on like you know
regulations and the need for them for
contractors and whatnot or you know
helping poor people out uh
with with social safety nets and like
anti-war stuff like that
now
he still defends weed even though he
doesn't have to that much because it's
more normalized and it's you know
decriminalized a lot in a lot of places
he that that other thing that he now
routinely talks about and can't shut the
[ __ ] up about and actually defends
relentlessly is like
covet conspiracies yeah and i don't know
how the [ __ ] that happened i think it
just broke his brain
that's when i think the the covet is
when it took a a really yeah and he like
moved to austin horrible turn yeah and
now he even even when he had like dr
rhonda patrick on who's a old friend of
his like
he was debating her about how she's
possibly wrong and he's right
um in the latest episode when he's
talking about jocko wilnik
he's like going through articles and
jamie's pulling up the article and
giving additional context that
immediately like destroys the narrative
that he's trying to build and he's just
like
pushing past it as quickly as possible
because like he doesn't want to he
doesn't want to recognize that he's in
the wrong he's like too deep in the
anti-covid or i think he feels
information
that i see a lot where it's like
he's now cultivated an audience
that holds him prisoner to his own ideas
for example the ivormectin the covid
there are so many people that have such
a strong belief in that and if people
deviate from that a little bit then it's
like you're out of the pack you're not
with us anymore and i think he's become
a prisoner to his own ideology now
and that if he know if he deviates he's
gonna get cancelled by his own fans he's
just a prisoner now yeah the coveted
stuff it also does take
unironically a big man a strong man a
confident man
to recognize and own up to their
mistakes
what are you saying i think it's it's
very weak and very selfish and very
childish
for joe rogan to
refuse to see the other side and refuse
to admit that like okay maybe i went a
little too ham on the [ __ ] covet
stuff
and that i'm wrong and there's been
plenty of [ __ ] scientists that have
come on my show that i've like basically
bullied into submission you know what i
mean by being like are you saying that
on the political spectrum
where would he fit on the scale of like
the strength of a man i don't really
he would
he would be on he would be on the bottom
left for sure a weak man he is a weak
man yeah for for
refusing to uh stray away and like
you know diving further and further into
the cesspool of
covered misinfo
you know
by the way here's another meme he posted
and this is like some boomer ass [ __ ]
[ __ ] and he got like over a million
likes like way more engagement than he
usually gets on his post which you
usually get like 150 000. that's how you
know instagram is like no longer the
young and like hip
it's over it don't like the young
platform yeah it's facebook well
everyone's on tick tock now yeah exactly
which i am as well i love tick tock i am
so addicted to tickets yeah i'm on tick
tock now more than any any social media
i spend hours on it and my for you page
is [ __ ] my for you page is wild dude
but that what i love about tick tock
while going a little bit of a tangent is
that you can find anything there bro i
don't care how long you spend on
instagram
how long you spend on youtube
twitter you will not see this [ __ ] on my
feed for example
uh let's say a seven-year-old dude
dancing in drag in an abandoned shed uh
with 20 likes that [ __ ] ends up on my
[ __ ] for you page it's nuts i i mean
i like
hot girls and i like you know like only
fans girls and stuff like that and then
i love that yeah and then i like you
know i'll look at like weird
compilations of like
deer hunters like talking about how you
know
let's go brand and that sort of [ __ ] so
tick-tock is i'm breaking the
algorithm's brain so tick tock finds a
way to show me only fans girls that
literally are promoting their only fans
on my for you page and their only fans
profiles are like literally them in like
all [ __ ] deer hunting camo getting
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] but like not actually not
actually on tick tock so they merged
your two interests they it's insane it's
like yeah like it's like an old fast
girl
brandon hashtag
deer hunting looking for white is that
your fantasy to [ __ ] a mega girl
i don't care like i don't have a a
preference like would you
date a girl
i have dated uh one of my ex-girlfriends
it was like very conservative
from alabama and we broke up because of
it like i was just like i can't do this
anymore here's conservative barbie this
might be a dream girl for you no no no
no
i i do watch her a lot though all of
trump supporters are an occult and
obsessed oh really well
oh
okay is she proving the point i don't
know yeah she's saying we are yeah
where's your daddy by the way i wanted
to show this meme so he posted this halo
this is like by the way he's like 15
years late to this meme yeah the year is
2034. the cash me outside girl is
president there are 67
298 genders it's illegal to have an
opinion i'm the last straight male this
is my story
yeah i love this meme because it's like
the cash me outside girl
okay this was literally made 10 years
ago yes and he just found it yes he he's
posting it like yo this is so funny like
dude you're a comedian like what the
[ __ ] are you interviewing i forget he's
a comedian sometimes what are you doing
yeah this is like literally cancer
anti-comedy this is the comedy cemetery
this is where jokes go to die is joe
rogan's uh instagram page even if i were
to take like the most centrist position
on this i would say like you know what
kills comedy just
seeking validation from a group of
individuals who will just [ __ ] clap
like a bunch of uh you know like like a
bunch of [ __ ] seals at sea world uh
exclusively uh at whatever you pump out
because it agrees with your point of
view your preconceived notion your
biases right and that's precisely what
this is they're just everyone is liking
that because oh i agree yeah he's right
and maybe this will own the lips it's
like no [ __ ] this [ __ ] is like
this is so bad even liberals don't get
mad at this anymore it's like so old
that even like the most rad lib like
[ __ ] sjw or whatever is not going to
get mad at this
because it's laughable but
the guy it's just he's so desperate to
be the victim it's like
you see it's illegal to have an opinion
it's like you're paid hundreds of
millions of dollars to spread covet
misinformation
as far as i'm aware
you're not being oppressed bro no what
no joe rogan is not even remotely
oppressed he's oppressed by the 70 000
genders
like dude have you not been able to like
get on that page yet i mean it's just
sad
so anyway joe biden has a better
position on gender than joe rogan who's
like 200 years old you remember that
video where like the girl comes up the
turning point usa girl comes with the
joe biden and it's like how many genders
are there joe biden
and he's like uh at least three
there you go that's a good answer he's
trying
i don't know i wouldn't know how to
answer that question i don't know either
no i don't know my answer my answer is
the meme was like no no i just got here
i think that's actually a pretty good
answer yeah i don't know i just got here
all right
i think what joe actually said is a
pretty good answer at least three
yeah
at least three
that's great i it's like a very slick
moment from joe and he's like what is
their actual right answer i don't know
as many uh
i don't care yeah i don't care i like i
accept all genders here is uh
here's the yes man in his uh
and his comments joe dead laughing are
you [ __ ] seriously dead laughing that
is real the real palm the real real punk
is when you
wear a button-up suit with their [ __ ]
with your
your little tie look at this all the way
up to your neckline look at this guy
crying and clapping the cash me outside
girl [ __ ] top tier comedy i've never
heard that one
it's so good
oh this is the milk guy you got another
boy
no exciting full full send moment okay
first of all it's bradley martin the
steroids have rotted his brain okay so
are you still sure you want to go on uh
mail enhancements because you'll end up
like bradley martin no you're going to
end up just typing yo's on youtube hot
and yeah dude
you keep saying you want to get go on
roy
i'm i'm urging you against it
i don't want to go work out at the zoo
i'm just telling you bro you don't need
steroids don't take steroids not yet but
when my when my team levels decline dude
i'm [ __ ] you can take
that's disgusting that's not that is
that is that's maddie baby
no i don't think he says he's natty can
i ask you a question what's up google uh
liver king dan you know about the liver
king oh my god
he's one of my favorites on tick tock me
too his body is so i love him i was just
literally watching videos of him and
like making fun of him with my friends
this i love liver king he's all over my
feet i'm fascinated by him me too so do
you think he's natty the [ __ ] no look at
his abs have you ever seen abs like that
[ __ ] out of here
zoom up on his abs it looks like he has
ab implants i mean i've never seen
absolutely he says he's natty but like
no of course he's not [ __ ] natty dude
are you kidding me hold on look look oh
let me explains okay let me pull up his
tick tock is this the dude that eats
like 20 patties
yeah he he'll eat like 20 patties he has
like bone marrow like he eats raw he
eats like raw beef raw liver he eats
liver with every meal
yeah he's a liver king so hold on let me
show cause i love this guy i'm glad
you're familiar with it oh dude i love
him dude are you [ __ ] kidding me look
how red he is always
yeah he's super red he always looks like
he's got like thyroid thyroid problems
or something i don't know what the
[ __ ] going on wait why is it bar
everything but okay liver king here this
is who i want but he's super [ __ ]
interesting i don't get he seems rich
too i guess he sells some weird
supplements yeah well here i don't
know
here these are the ones so this is his
resting body
yeah his he looks like a ninja turtle
his abs look like the back of a ninja
turtle he's awesome i love him like
first of all i've said this before like
getting that body steroids no steroids
doesn't matter like it is a profound
accomplishment even with bradley martin
and stuff so let's dispel this rumor or
a notion that like oh if i just did
steroids i would look like that no you
wouldn't that requires a tremendous
amount of work this guy is insanely
dedicated that's the obvious so whenever
i see people like that i still respect
them regardless i'm sorry i know people
but you don't lie about taking steroids
that's [ __ ] up
yeah uh i do think that's silly and it's
just as harmful as like girls saying
that their bodies are natural when it's
not
[ __ ] up it's harmful yeah but these
keto dudes these like primal dudes like
especially liver king because he like
has a routine yeah uh on wednesdays he
rests but on saturday he does a
simulated hunt yeah he's stimulated he
goes on sunday we simulate a hunt we
gotta go pretend like we got a carcass
and then we feast okay so please pull up
his latest simulated hunt video where he
throws a spear at like uh a fake deer
yeah
uh it's on his instagram hold on i want
to watch him eat him third one i gotta
literally look at this morning i'm gonna
i'm gonna watch the people need to watch
me fast by doing a simulated successful
hunt now it is time to re-feed and we're
gonna start with 30 grams of a delicious
protein shake we got liver because liver
is king three ounces
we have a huge huge huge chunk of femur
bone yes you know what all of that bone
marrow is going to be going here we have
some raw testicle about two or three
ounces of broccoli baby you know what it
is
you know what the [ __ ] it is that's
dedication that's so nice you know how
you get abs like that
eating raw testies bruh
it's just so nasty but here pull up the
uh pull up that one yeah yeah look watch
so this is how many men out there are
doing what we are hardwired to do are
you fighting hunting providing
protecting preserving you don't have to
go all in and start throwing spin you
can fight by looking for opportunities
to scare you okay so let's watch
[Music]
by the way he's so jacked like i don't
even think he'd be good in a fight hold
on
oh dude you got him except you couldn't
even hit center mass dumbass that
[ __ ] deer would have gotten away
liver king
you didn't have eight other tries you
couldn't have just shot you couldn't
have just shot this again and again and
again until you actually hit [ __ ]
center mass there i'm gonna i'm actually
gonna step in in favor of liver king
here no
shot that deer would have gone away no
well back in the day our biggest
competitive advantage is that we're
endurance we have two legs we can out
and door any animal you stick them with
the spear and then you chase them down
you follow the blood trail you would
definitely get that damn you're you are
you are a liver king yeah you're a liver
head i mean i gotta stand up for liberty
on this one saying is all i'm saying is
like it would have looked cooler if he
actually [ __ ] hit center mass on that
you know what i mean he just what makes
you think this isn't the 30th try and
this is the best shot they've got yeah
that's why he gave up after he's like
[ __ ] this all right put this up deborah
i personally don't think he would ever
landed that shot on a real year on a
[ __ ] day they would have seen that
coming from like a mile away
so
the thing that is also hilarious about
this is like because my trainer loves
him like he loves him and talks about
him all the time and i love dunking on
liver king but also like i'm fascinated
by him he's very entertaining
so two things one
are you familiar with the concept of uh
breatharians or
yeah vegetarians but for breath they
just breathe so these kinds of gurus is
that what you mean they just live on
they just live on uh sunlight and yeah
i'm familiar with that so they're all
[ __ ] fake obviously you would die
right after a certain point yeah and
they always used to i mean they used to
do this back in the day
the thing is that's literally what liver
king is doing with his dietary habits
and also what he is omitting from
the public record of like what his true
regimen looks like right you think he's
lying about what he eats
i think he eats that sort of stuff but
it's not every meal
like i don't think he i don't think he
you know he probably eats like chicken
and broccoli and [ __ ] like he doesn't
[ __ ] just eat he likes carrots he
carbs up yeah he eats potatoes they look
delicious he says and we got carbs today
because i earned it yeah and maple uh
maple syrup well the maple syrups on the
liver every meal yeah
you see you underestimated no no i you
you and i are both liverpool
we're just on the different end of the
spectrum on liberty i'm skeptical
you're fully tapped in yeah i'm sipping
for the liver kit yeah well what's funny
about the whole liver king online fandom
you could call it is the debate over if
he's natty or if whatever it's pretty
bone and skin on sardines we've got a
couple of ounces of some salmon eggs we
have a pile of potatoes this is
cardboard number one so good we've got
our vegetables aka pork rinds we got
liver king concoction
pork rinds vegetables yeah they do look
like cauliflower from afar so i always
thought that well that's what that was
that's funny
what is the concoction i want to know do
you know what that is
i think it's some kind of yogurt maple
syrup and like liver or ground organs or
something yeah it's disgusting
oh
[ __ ] wait i want to show the ones with
all the burger packet patties yeah yeah
yeah so he does the simulated hunt where
he carry stuff he does like a mile walk
or something with like 200 pounds on him
and
so the second thing i was going to say
now that you've owned my first point on
liver king and him being fake go ahead
the second thing is like dog they did
this out of necessity okay
like all of those cavemen
if they had the opportunity to get
[ __ ] food delivered from their
grocery store would do that well okay
like so it's profoundly privileged for
us all right well let me just agree with
you there i'm just kidding okay actually
yeah if if you want to be a [ __ ] real
caveman then you know
what are you doing with the stove and
hot water don't don't live in a [ __ ]
you know two million dollar uh mega man
louis abysbo
or wherever you know with breakfast
lunch and dinner yeah
raw liver we have more liver on top of
liver this is liver potato leftover from
thanksgiving and we have a beautiful
piece of bone marrow here a little piece
of uh i do [ __ ] with the bone marrow
though i don't know if i'd eat it wrong
somebody patty
he claims
and people debate that he eats every
patty i've seen him eat four patties
like there is one video of him eating
but he never actually shows how many
patties he's eating i mean what is it 20
patties
we can count them up that's is this one
or two right here no it's one
that's four
seven eight that's ten patty oh my god
that's 15 patties i could eat i could
eat ten
like easy
so i'm not but after the 10th it's going
to get hard
yeah and all that liver and [ __ ] okay he
says he does okay i always say that get
used to it um i'll probably be having
this section right here okay so he
doesn't have dinner today he said he's
only eating half everything here welcome
back he's the real deal guys my favorite
video is of him shooting the beyond meat
okay
he he shoots the beyond meat okay
because like haha [ __ ] you know [ __ ]
meat substitutes which like i i am a
[ __ ] meat boy i love me i don't know
why you gotta hate on like meat
substitutes no but he's got nothing to
do with you so he shoots it and then if
you look at the comments
he has like this
long [ __ ]
get this [ __ ] no music
look at his back it looks [ __ ]
cancerous he looks awesome it looks like
he has cancer
well i mean he says he he doesn't use
sunscreen so he's definitely gonna oh
yeah cancer is an issue bro
come on man no wonder he's so red all
the time yeah
um like a human hot dog dude i love him
so much um but the beyond meat one
that's one that's when i was sold on him
because him and his wife control the
account
and uh someone was like well i'm vegan
like why would you say this liver king
and he wrote this like entire [ __ ]
dissertation under it like you know
vegans are incredibly ethical and you
know i love i love vegans and i'm like
bro it's this is under a video where you
shot a beyond me why did he shoot the
beyond yeah what i'm saying he's like
he's a kind-hearted man that's when i
realized he does seem like a good guy
yeah that's part of the if he seemed
like a douche i wouldn't i wouldn't even
[ __ ] that's when i realized like liver
king you know
you're like an onion you know we're
peeling different layers players yeah
and we're and we're peering in and well
you know seeing the real liver and
there's all these videos about liver
king and they're all interesting i just
i love the whole thing and i'm not even
into fitness or anything i just find it
disgusting and weird and interesting you
should get liberating to train you i
should get him on the show what the [ __ ]
yeah get him on the show and have him
train are you kidding me i've died that
chain probably weighs the same amount as
me 120
you can carry it you know about that
chain 120 pounds yeah
so was that even impressive what he was
doing
yeah 120 pounds was a lot of weight i
have a weight vest it's like 80 pounds
that's a lot why are you saying that i
can do it then you can do it
i think you could do it you're good
your body no i think you could carry 120
pound chain for sure
over my shoulders maybe for
if it rested on you like that
you could you could say i'm just i'm
confused is it impressive for liver king
to do because do you want me to bring my
80 pound weight vest uh yeah you can
like try and put it on yes okay
yes i do i mean i'm trying to feel weird
i'm sure i could do it
yeah
but what's so impressive about what if i
can do it it's not impressive well if
you're walking around with it for a mile
then it's insane okay okay i see yeah
it's the
it's it's the repetition the endurance
like that's when that's when it becomes
a workout
got it putting it on once for like three
seconds and like standing up straight
you can do it yeah i can do that
all right let's talk about first i want
to talk about uh dave rubin being a
dumbass of course in a freak show
dave rubin uh always has to be the
victim as all right wing
grifters are that's basically their
whole identity is like you know
white
white victimhood
so he says in a time when we are all
expected to be obsessed with other
people's health
what should i do about this obese man
whose belly is
falling into my seat
he's more at risk for covet too should i
report him
show him youtube fitness videos what
would be what would a good obedient
citizen do yeah when i was really fat i
saw one youtube fitness video
from a random person who was sitting
next to me and i was like wow that's
it's over now i now i have recognized
i'm fat now the rock the rock song
starts playing in your head yeah it's
about tribe it's about power
we stay hungry so he took a creep shot
of a this is dave ruben by the way he's
flying coach what a [ __ ] scumbag
[Laughter]
like to be honest like you're going to
sell your soul
uh as a gay man in simping for people
that hate you and you and you're still
facing the coach you're right he's a
broke boy it's like if you're gonna sell
your soul like that that you should at
least be in first class [ __ ]
you're selling your soul food for dimes
on the dollar
yeah
i'm surprised i thought his channel was
doing better like uh surprising that
he's like still you know relegated to
coach
yeah because it just goes to show you
that while they'll pay him to be the the
uh obedient dance monkey
uh but they'll never let him in the in
the
the real big boys
well i think that's also partially
because like
he's just
he is he is no drip okay he has no swag
he gets swag he's just so boring get
behind that curtain like when i say swag
i don't mean like actually good uh
articles of clothing or anything he's
just like incredibly boring he's not a
very entertaining person he's not
insightful he's not smart yeah not
interesting he's literally just the
poster child for how easy it is to make
a career out of grip god damn 11k views
in one day
i have a youtube channel with 800 000
subs and i'm pumping out videos that
have at least 200k
yeah every day yeah you know your
channel does well i enjoy it too i watch
all those clips this is
surprising that dave rubin is like oh my
god
yeah so like you have a single basically
when i was in character
as the uh uncle what was my name on when
we were doing the thanksgiving
uncle hank i feel like i could have a
more successful career yeah than dave
rubin as uncle hank i use dave rubin as
an example of like how easy it is to
grift as a right winger on the way on
the internet and like how you can still
be
you can make a comfortable living as
long as you just like repeat the right
talking points because he is just
impossible to watch he's just like not
fun he's not funny he's not even like
stupid enough he's very stupid but like
he's somehow not stupid enough to like
watch and clown on like jlp for example
jc lee peterson he's just a towel
a white power i mean yeah cause he's not
fun he's not educated he's not
insightful yeah but anyway he took a
creep shot of a fat guy and he's saying
i guess people asking you to wear a mask
so that you don't spread a dangerous
uh virus is
the same as telling fat people they need
to lose weight i don't understand the
logic there buddy but no i i mean
there's this is a classic conservative
trope which is like oh if we're gonna
tell people to get the uh you know
vaccine well what about the obesity
problems
being fat is not contagious it's it's
stupid it's not even though they will
immediately point back to the study it's
like considered hereditary technically
because like um obesity is it is it
contagious it's not a transmissible
disease okay that's the that's the
proper term before someone tries to dunk
obviously
um because you know
dietary habits you can basically get
from your
family members and also uh what about
flying next to someone on a plane can
you get fat from flying no no you can
cope
um
so the thing that's like also incredibly
cringe about that obviously aside from
like like this dude is just bullying the
guy who doesn't even know he uh he's
doing this to him he's being [ __ ] fat
like dude
this is what i say about fat shaming all
the time as a former fat who still
thinks uh
no i was real fat back in the day i i
used to be yeah oh yeah is there any
pictures of you um i wrote a health
article like way back in the morning
google pike or fat it'll come up
yep they're the one on the left yeah
okay yeah you were pretty chunky yeah
got out that's not even my worst but
so
but what i was gonna say is and i'm
still how old were you here
i don't remember
well there you go look at that
inspirational oh wow you were fat that's
not me i'm kidding
but look at you now bro
look at that himba i mean i don't look
like that anymore i look at that bro i i
definitely i definitely waiting since
and i'm now losing it again but
um
the thing oh look at this look at the
young one i know it's crazy
[Laughter]
what about the glow up that's pretty
awesome though that you can you know
get jacked
yeah and also just be super tall
that was definitely always a benefit for
sure but it makes it a little bit harder
to lose the weight and like look
proportional when you're taller but you
know wow dude really this is a weird one
is that really you yeah oh yes your head
is tiny
it's just i'm wearing a triple xl shirt
i thought that was photoshopped bro it's
not photoshopped
pecker is mad
okay it's just whatever okay enough
about me and my
you look great normally size head that
kind of looks small sometimes
the thing i was just gonna say is like
as far as fat shaming goes like first of
all
empirical evidence uh shows that fat
shaming does not work and as a matter of
fact it
hurts people uh and and uh harms them
and prevents them from losing weight
because they uh go back to a depressive
spiral of eating more to cope with that
okay
um so people that say like foot shooting
refreshing helps like no it doesn't shut
the [ __ ] up you're just being a [ __ ]
and i do fat shaming uh from time to
time as well yeah not to but like if you
think that fat people don't know that
they're fat let me tell you
no they definitely do they know every
day they know when they wake up they
know when they look in the mirror
that's it just hangs on them every
single moment of their lives so you
repeating that in public to you know
dunk on them
it's not helpful i i think making fun
fact shaming someone's like uh addiction
shaming it's like you [ __ ] junky
piece of [ __ ] it's like you know people
understand that's not helpful
but um they but it's the same thing look
at the discord
oh my god
[Laughter]
it's about drive it's about well i know
who's more driven
and i know who's more hungry
i am
more hungry
you don't even have to think about it
dude so was this a progress shot what's
the story on the photo on the left um
i didn't used to take a lot of photos uh
shirtless photos when i was really fat
but that was like after it already
started working out okay so it was a
progress fake yeah that's good if it was
like the one that i could find that was
like bad
it's not that bad but you know shout
outs you look great i'm proud of you
thank you you put in the work it's about
power it's about driving yeah absolutely
i do i do stay hungry and i do devour
absolutely shout outs out to the rock
shut up next game
shut up [ __ ] all right come on rock
we're being nice yeah
i'm sorry i'll vote for you
so i wanted to next talk about uh
lowenbo lauren bobert
who is basically um
just openly
islamophobic in the most disgusting way
to be honest with you we really
shouldn't even tolerate this kind of
absolutely [ __ ] disgusting racism in
our country she is such a disgusting
creep
oh yeah so there there's this clip that
surfaced or i guess there's a series of
clips is that right
this clip was the original one that like
got a lot of attention
but then we found out that uh you know
this was her bit that she's been doing
for years
she's been killing this is a part of her
fight five
she takes she's been taking the show on
the road yeah so here's lauren bober um
here's the comment she refuses to
apologize for it i'm sorry for you
so uh the other night on the house floor
was not the my first jihad squad moment
uh so
i was getting not a lot of laughter
there she was pausing for applause you
wanna hit the full screen on there so we
can we can see it in all his glory i
wanna see the rustic vibes in the
background
uh so
look at that clock in the background to
an elevator with one of my staffers
and he and i are we're leaving the
capitol we're going back to my office
and we get an elevator and i see a
capitol police officer running hurriedly
to the elevator i see
fret all over his face and he's reaching
and i'm like
the door's shutting like i can't i can't
open it like what's happening
i look to my left
and there she is
on omar
and i said well
she doesn't have a backpack we should be
fine
are they in joe rogan's studio right now
is that where this is taking place yeah
george was like yeah let's have lauren
bob yeah you know really smart lady yeah
i heard she got good ideas yeah what do
you mind omar
i said well
she doesn't have a backpack we should be
fine
you know what's ironic is that this is
who actually carries a gun
into the halls of congress yeah she's a
[ __ ] terror she's terrified and yet
she's accusing
ilhan omar of being a threat to her
safety yeah remember the school shooting
video she put out as a campaign ad where
she was like don't come to congress
tomorrow like i'm bringing my glock with
me
like
like it's just so ironic like if
anyone's a threat to safety it's you
she's like marjorie you're fine you're
you're one of the cool ones
wasn't she the one who was like i refuse
to get metal detected
after the january 6 they're like you
have to go through a metal detector
because we don't trust some of you
cycles on the right you're bringing
weapons into the chamber you're bringing
insurrectionists into the halls of
congress yeah
like so she's like i will not go through
that metal detector
um
she is it seems like she's just like
positioning herself as a as like a media
personality and that's why she's doing
stuff like he just wants that fox
spot yeah
yeah that's good money she has to go
blonde yeah here bober clashes with
capital police
what in the gods freaking
i closed it right i didn't think you
were going to acknowledge it yeah bober
clashes with capitol police after
setting off cool as well what happened
there yeah it's a little effect we have
here do it on hassan
yeah sometimes we just deep fry it
that's dude that's what you get for
seven
gajillion dollars right when you put a
studio like that together only the best
yeah we have a lot we have a live uh
special effects team that works
there's 20 of them on the lower level
yeah
they killed yeah they loved that i had
one floor to go and i was like uh did i
say it why not i looked over and i said
oh look the jihad squad decided to show
up for work today
she's so happy while being strapped
while being strapped with a weapon
staffers on twitter the talk for her she
she's not tough in person she doesn't
yes
yeah so i mean that's just openly racist
a freak show it's disgusting it's
harmful if there's a person who's the
toughest in congress
no one gets it uh from all ends like she
does liberals [ __ ] [ __ ] on her
regularly uh republicans of course go
the extra mile regularly and like say
the most insane [ __ ] about her like it's
wild that they can just like
theorize that she like [ __ ] her
brother you know what i mean like that's
a thing that they're just like around
they stated as fact yeah which is like
you know
insane it's like a
stereotype i guess of of yeah that's the
the
right-wing uh you know white supremacist
narrative is that like muslims are
[ __ ] they're good
[ __ ] their cousins is going on in
damn [ __ ] mississippi yeah and
kentucky that's the funny thing is that
like uh tucker carlson has like openly
defended uh this famous white
supremacist pastor like cult leader
in the past
for like uh executing marriages between
like little girls and and old ass dudes
i forget what his name was this was all
in the uncovered like old school uh
tapes of his where he also famously said
you know uh iraqis are primitive apes
that deserve to be bombed yeah
yeah so tucker carlson straight up okay
why people do it half a million
civilians killed at least in iraq yeah
and tucker's like yeehaw
hates war though he
he now hates war if you ask glenn
greenwald
warren jeffs is the name of the uh yeah
warren jeffs uh mormon polygamist uh
preacher that uh tucker vehemently
defends so anyway bobert gave somewhat
of an apology i apologize to anyone the
muslim community i've offended with my
comments
about representative omar i have reached
out to office to speak with her directly
there are plenty of policy differences
focused on without this unnecessary
distraction okay well let's see how that
apology went however the call between
them didn't go well bobert shifted gears
doubling down here she is describing her
call
with uh omar
hey everyone this is lauren with a quick
update bro she is such a karen like oh
my gosh she is like just she's someone
freaking out in the parking lot of
walmart if she wasn't in congress i mean
she is in congress and still doing that
right so right yeah she stayed true to
her roots
god just got a load of that face on a
phone call i had today with squad member
ilhan omar i had reached out to her
friday and three days later i was able
to connect with her on the phone because
i wanted to let her know directly that i
had reflected on my previous remarks now
as a strong christian woman who values
faith deeply i never want anything i say
to offend someone's religion so i told
her that even after so why the [ __ ] are
you calling her
jihad
the jihad squad well you know because
is that not offensive i mean what the
[ __ ] are you talking about the jihad
squad well
it's because ilhan omar is muslim and so
is it
and uh
but the but the real she'll claim that
it's because of their defense of of uh
you know palestinians their defense of
you know muslim victims of american
imperialism
and then they'll go so far say it's
actually because they support al qaeda
which is not real that's never been a
thing that is a totally made-up [ __ ]
[ __ ] take and the only reason why it
sticks is because
shocker because they're [ __ ] muslim
yeah okay that's it
like
during my 9 11 saga with dan crenshaw
one of my criticisms with dan credshaw
literally was that he was
he was refusing to stop arms sales to
saudi arabia
as saudi arabia was engaging in an
ongoing
genocide in yemen okay man-made famine
dan crenshaw was standing against bernie
sanders and other members of the jihad
squad in uh stopping the arms sales to
saudi arabia
those arms ended up literally in the
hands of al qaeda okay
so this idea that like uh it's the
jihad squad or or progressives that are
actually
uh you know pro al qaeda and not the
american government and the liberals and
republicans both that continue to give
weapons to saudi arabia is laughable and
the only reason why it sticks and it
stuck with me too they said like i
support al qaeda and i love 911 or
whatever is because if you're muslim on
the internet it's like so easy to just
be like oh yeah he loves terrorism
and it's a trope it's an old school
it's a really [ __ ] up damaging one
that
needs to stop immediately and you know
it's basically the same thing as saying
well you know she's a clan member and
well maybe she is yeah she got hella uh
how did he lose his eye did someone did
was he like
are you trying to bait him
[Laughter]
i don't know i don't know what happened
uh i think it was ied or something i i
don't know
what i said about that what i i mean i
don't give a [ __ ] what i said about it i
always thought that wasn't that bad what
you said what i said about it was a was
a joke about and it wasn't about like
his eye in general it was about his
position as like someone who was
defending endless war and him who made a
personal sacrifice in his mind okay uh
and then not learned the lessons from
that and still was sending young men and
women overseas to [ __ ] have an even
worse fate than himself to die basically
for nothing but the military industrial
complexes you know bottom line and i
find that disgusting i don't give a [ __ ]
i don't offer unconditional support to
veterans
across the board they all do deserve
health care just like every american
deserves healthcare no matter what their
background anyway the joke was that he
got [ __ ] in the eye by uh
i mean that's not that bad well the joke
there was that like
it's just a funny gag the the brave
mujahideen comment there was actually
about i feel very very indicated about
this now because at the time no one
[ __ ] knew what i meant or like my
community knew what i meant but most
people did not know because they were
like what would you oh wait okay so
people were goofing on people got mad
not because you say he got skull [ __ ]
but because you called the muhajeed
brave which was a rambo meme or
something right so yeah uh this film is
dedicated to the brave mujahideen yeah
it's like an old rambo meme right people
claim that it wasn't on the vhs tapes or
whatever but like the point is
i'm not the uh what i was referencing
was ronald reagan right when i said
brave mujahideen ronald reagan
and you are raising their soldiers yeah
this film is dedicated to the brave
muhajin fighters
um but yeah this is not my position this
was the position of the american state
department which uh armed the the muslim
which then you know branched off into
the taliban to the they took the job and
they're like he supports terrorism yeah
which is ironic because the american
government yeah you are satirizing the
the
actual president yeah who said that so
there you go
so that you they [ __ ] know what was
the name
[ __ ] by uh no okay no not to my
knowledge ronald reagan named one of the
space missions after the mujahideen like
they they met with the leaders they they
considered them to be similar akin to
the founding uh the founding fathers
so i mean operation cyclone is like a
well-documented
cycle is a well-documented operation and
it precedes it it predates ronald
reagan's administration even that like
america always wanted to
uh
support the mujahideen the islam
islamist fundamentalists okay and some
of them were not by the way there's a
lot of conflict there as well but they
wanted to support them because they were
expressly anti-ussr at a time when the
communist government of afghanistan
was uh engaging in like a brutal
anti uh islamic uh
you know
conquest over over the more rural areas
like destroying moss and [ __ ] like that
it's a really long and convoluted uh
story that has been told a million times
over now on the 20th anniversary of 9 11
with our evacuation from afghanistan
which is why i feel so vindicated about
it because now everyone gets what i was
saying yeah a lot of people do at least
but before they were like what the [ __ ]
i get i see how they spun that against
you yeah i thought they were just mad
that you were denigrating a veteran or
something which i'm sure well that too
that definitely plays a role in it but
like that's because you're like you know
turkish they can be like he's
a terrorist sympathizer put out a public
statement unlike
bobert to that effect she said that she
still wanted a public apology because
what i had done wasn't good enough so i
reiterated to her what i had just said
she kept asking for a public apology so
i told ilhan omar that she should make a
public apology to [ __ ]
flipped it on you yeah through the
american people for her anti-american
anti-semitic anti-police rhetoric sounds
like a good apology and i continued to
press back this is some caring [ __ ]
representative omar hung up on me
rejecting an apology and hanging up on
someone i cannot believe she hung up on
me when i told her she needed to
apologize for [ __ ] her brother yeah
or like
the my favorite part about this is like
she's supposed to be like a brave free
speech defender
right
and then her counter is like you need to
apologize to the american people for
police anti-police rhetoric like what
the [ __ ] are you saying dude the police
are perfect there is not a police
officer who has done anything wrong ever
and for you to criticize one off that
arrested me what except for the ones
that arrested me and my husband and my
husband for flashing his wee-wee uh at a
bowling alley
yeah he her husband interestingly
exposed himself to minors
oh wow
uh conch let me read the headline here
congressional candidate loan bob has a
history of minor arrests court no shows
so she's actually been arrested if you
want to talk about four times a threat
to society she looks better is the she
looks pretty good though she looks good
there like with the crackhead vibes i
don't know why
this is like the before and after meth
photo you know where you like don't do
math she looks good there she looks
better
for sure
which we now know is uh you know meth is
better than being a conservative
apparently i know this is you on being a
conservative grifter i mean we got
lauren bobert on the one hand and then
michael pillow mr pillow owner of mike
hello hello
he literally him apple thing i thought
he was the only one who was better
when he had a crack addiction
oh he looked good on crack
pull up hold that up there's no photos
of him on crap i mean maybe there are
but he's certainly doesn't look good now
okay
let's see
oh to the left he looks like tom selleck
oh yeah he looks he looks uh he looks
like [ __ ]
you could never get yourself outside
yeah
yeah you just you went from uh loving
crack to loving jesus which is way
better my pillow
was blessed with the heart with the
blood of christ
yeah the more pillows you oh look at
that
oh i used to smoke meth and crack
now when i found god i sell pillows
i'm just saying that like he substituted
he substituted a crack cocaine addiction
or meth addiction
for
you know q anon conspiracies okay he
basically
it is literally the the uh heroine to to
uh what's the
what's the thing that they do
no not finn no um the the therapy one
that's like government methadone
methadone yeah this is his methadone
basically thank you
like his substitution was you know
loving donald trump
i sneak a pube and every pillow i sell
in the coding you'll never find it but i
know it's there you got it you got to
hit the more like uh you know midwestern
like he sounds like jesse ventura a
little bit you know he's like i'm
michael pillow i'm mike lindell
and i love my pillows
is part of cancel culture 101 in a
pillar of the democrat party make no
mistake i will continue to fearlessly
put america first never sympathizing
with terrorists unfortunately
can't say the same thing she must be she
must be great to date the funniest part
of this is that like her involvement
with the january six insurrectionists
and like her defense for that he's a
terrorist like that's the that's the
[ __ ]
actual terrorist can you imagine if it
was a group of muslims that stormed the
capital and led by illinois we would
have been you know what if there was
muslims
we would be invading iraq again yeah
they would like it would literally hang
ilhan a [ __ ] public gallow
we would have done a full-scale ground
invasion of like
uh morocco or something related every
muslim every muslim country gets get
some after that one but like when lauren
bobert does it and when it's white
supremacists and like you know white
nationalists and and other republicans
uh that are not
as aggro about it but whatever
uh and and they're being defended by
lauren bobert of the liked and that's
fine that's just american they were just
doing america too hard
you know
but you know she's not a terror
sympathizer you know omar is no she's
not she's a straight-up terrorist
in our country
in colorado
please know i appreciate you and your
support i appreciate you understanding
is her is her husband a sex criminal
like is he a verified registered sex
criminal
um because that seems like exactly that
seems like something that would happen
when you expose yourself to minor yeah
i'm gonna look into it
i love i love lo and bulbert
he he did do uh i have james time for
lewd exposure in a bowling alley and she
was there i have great respect for men
that show their genitals to minors yeah
couple were 86 from colorado bowling
alley in 2004 after jason bobert his
name is jason but with the wife jason
bober
come on over here little missy of course
take a peek of my [ __ ] his name is jason
with a y in between like he's not j a s
o n it's
jason it's j-a-z-o-n no it's j-a-y-s-o-n
oh that's white there's a y in the
middle white trashes that's right i'm
jason beauvoir jason
and i exposed myself to two young women
in a bowling alley in colorado all the
way back in what was it
yeah jason bober
what so is he on a is he on a sex
criminal i'm looking i mean his wife was
17 at the time jason bobert was 24 and
he flashed his [ __ ] his wife to be
lauren bobert was there as well as a 17
year old those are good christian values
but i tell you what man i'm a good
christian i believe in getting drunk
showing your genitals to minors and
that's just the good christian way i
don't [ __ ] around with no goddamn
terrorism
that's why you want to hear the story
the minors yeah please trish and i were
standing at the snack bar and she came
up and looked at my tattoo on my back
and she pulled down her sock and said
look mine is fading she wrote the word
tattoo may have been a minute then jason
said i have a tattoo on my dick
what a good christian boy trisha and i
said yeah whatever and turned away to
ignore him coombs continued this is the
victim and then jason came up behind us
and pulled his penis i don't know why
i'm reading it with this accent and
jesus came up and behind us and pulled
his penis out of his pants his thumb was
covering the head all i saw was the
shaft trish and i turned away and went
and told him just the shaft your honor
no big deal then i didn't even shovel my
and lauren and lauren
her [ __ ] kick ass was there 17 years
old uh you know jason is 24 material she
thought yeah she saw that and she was
like i locked eyes with that penis
tattoo and i said to myself this is the
man this is a good christian man that i
can grow a good christian family with
yup that's right
and then call other religious people
terrorists yup damn nothing on bobert a
sex criminal
no no no bulbert was just there i'm i'm
giving you the him i mean
no it's their husband this is the story
no i just checked the sex offender list
okay got it no no i mean they might have
expunged it my wife is a powerful
congress lady she got my sex criminal
charge uh expunged yeah
and now i'm back in the bowling alley
showing my shaft to you and now you know
she's voting against the violence
against women act saying she was opposed
to the bill because it would secure
abortion rights i'm pro-violence against
women yeah
they have it coming damn it
[Laughter]
it's great
um
here uh here the response from bobert
supporters make it clear they weren't
happy she
even sort of apologized at all yeah i
was surprised uh
here let's see i call let's see some of
the comments you ought to have ignored
that jihadist anti-american [ __ ] wow
you're not contemporaries at all please
ignore that [ __ ] daughter of a
suicide belt
wow
i mean like we shouldn't really downplay
what a disgusting hateful
board like these people are ready for
genocide like i mean this 100 they yeah
did you not see ian han omar also uh in
the press conference
showed a voicemail that she had received
from one of these lovely american
individuals that started off by calling
her and sand n-word and then following
with uh threats or rather promises that
they would kill her and that she would
be murdered for treason it's in the it's
the next link in the duck yeah is that
voicemail
oh elon played death threat she received
after beau bert's rant yeah
these people are like we need to
actually face this
be up front and real about what this is
this is
violent yeah racial
[ __ ] borderline or leading to
genocidal
mania i mean this is absolute
bigotry at the highest order that we've
it's just [ __ ]
it can't be tolerated it cannot be going
to play you
a voicemail
that we received
hours
after i got off the phone
after that graceful apology
after she posted her video
[Music]
oh my god we know what you're up to
you're all about taking over the country
don't worry there's planes
that will love the opportunity
to take you off the faces
come get that you [ __ ] muslim piece
of [ __ ] you jihadist
we know what you are
you're a [ __ ] freighter
you will not live much longer [ __ ] i
can
almost guarantee you that
these people are rising up
and you will be tried for a military
tribunal
why oh that's you know
and then the rest of it is just her
re-reading the transcript but
so
what i this is this is something that
like if you're if you're online if
you're a leftist online especially if
you're a leftist who's like a muslim
online this is i've i've heard those
exact same words verbatim okay a million
times over it's almost so that i feel
like there's a template somewhere where
they're just like repeating the same
[ __ ] talking points um
but in this situation like this is inan
omar gets it so much because
i remember a time when like
donald trump literally plastered her
face on like you know the jumbotrons or
whatever at the at the [ __ ] rallies
that he would do
saying
pretty much the exact same things that
uh was was circulating in that in that
letter
in that email blast that he may or may
not have uh sent out
the one we were talking about before the
show
where he said she [ __ ] her brother
apologies for [ __ ] your brother yeah
by the way every single every single
instance
j uh jesus from the big lebowski he was
a sex criminal
yeah
at a bowling alley nobody [ __ ] with
christian values i don't know if you're
a big lebowski no no i love
yeah this is the statement i'm confused
this looks real i don't know what yeah i
just couldn't find the archive post but
everybody on the conservative side
posted it and also they love it savage
trump listen to this uh
congressman ilhan omar should apologize
for marrying her brother
committing benny johnson got fired from
buzzfeed for
plagiarism
committing large-scale immigration
uh
large-scale immigration and election
fraud wishing death to israel for
essentially abandoning her former
country
fire emojis
that's just psychotic bro it's the
dangerous psycho [ __ ] i mean
it is a the ramblings of a genocidal
maniac it's just
it really is and i i i don't i know
people might say that's hyperbole but
they're making them
inhuman
they are attributing things that
obviously are fake
and they are riling they're making them
so sub-human that it's almost like
they're it's ex you can do whatever you
want to them that's the whole point
dehumanizing to that degree is the whole
point to like rile them up especially
when there's already like a lot of
animosity towards muslims automatically
because of our endless uh failure of uh
the war on terror which is a war on all
muslim nations
um so
it's really [ __ ] up i mean look post 9
11 america was like this was the this
was the most common
this was the normative position it's
just like if you're a muslim you're a
threat you're an enemy i'm terrified of
you and i will say whatever the [ __ ] i
want to you and people that i think are
muslim even if they're like sick for
example you know what's funny is like
we've been in this situation before with
the japanese after paul harbor and we
look back on that with disgust like how
can we do that it's like we're doing the
same thing some of us well i mean
historically yeah we don't look back
fondly on internment camp japanese and
term accounts at least the way i learned
it was always through the scope of like
we look how [ __ ] we are you know
and my liberal [ __ ]
my liberal circle race theory that's
critical race there you can't wait
anymore man they had to come man we had
to be sure that those japanese ain't
[ __ ]
double agents
yeah
um i'm in favor of a uh white internment
camps because january 6
we could we don't know which one of them
are double agents yeah
see your what you're doing right now is
exactly the same thing that every
conservative uh routinely fantasizes
about with respect to like muslims not
everyone but a lot of conservatives
openly talk about it and salivate over
this sort of [ __ ]
but like it is so beyond the scope of
comprehension or uh
it's so outside of like something that
could happen that when you say that
immediately everyone laughs you're like
what okay that's crazy because that's
that's the whole point it's like white
people are still considered the default
it's still considered the dominant class
or the dominant subgroup and it is uh
that doesn't mean that like white people
are all you know incredibly privileged
and they're all living in the lab of
luxury but that is one way that like
you know you never have to really think
about being an associate or associated
with like crimes or or horrible
fundamentalists
uh just by virtue of what your
background is
you know oh they found it
yeah this is on the website this is on
his website i i found it's worded
slightly differently but it's
essentially the same message so i think
this confirms but it's also not
surprising because he said all of those
things in the past right at his rallies
and whatnot right apologize for marrying
her brother and you know that's the
president so like there's millions tens
of millions of people
who will read that and take it at face
value because it's the president yeah
and they love him they like are in love
with him like the president is not
supposed to
say stuff like that no just not normal
no but okay here's the other um
it's funny they say that um they call
them the squad the jihad squad i mean
bober and m and marger and taylor gr
gross what do we call them the uh
[ __ ]
those two clowns if they're the
uh jihad squad then these guys are like
the uh
eha i'll call it the clan rally
or that that's more direct yeah
they are
the wizards the grand wizards for what
they've been saying
here she is with um
um basically uh
toxic avenger
this is um
steve bannon steve bannon who
basically aided the uh insurrection and
worked to undermining our democracy
um too for what they brought they're
pro-americans they've been taking ethan
you know they're pro-white america
they're so pro-america it's like dude
there's nothing when we say funnier to
me than people like marjorie titan green
and and [ __ ] lauren bobert over here
who uh aided and embedded the january
16th insurrectionist who like advocated
for them and still [ __ ] go out the
bat for them
saying that like they are the real pro
americans and that that was actually a
patriotic thing you know i mean january
6 was a patriotic thing this story we
were just doing a tour it's crazy how
many people actually believe that never
happened now
yeah because of
psychos like this they were on a
peaceful tour but that is i'm sorry that
is just straight up people still get
butthurt over this but that's like
that's white supremacy it's when white
people can engage in acts of uh domestic
terror that like any other subgroup
would immediately be vilified for my
solution to this isn't to vilify all
white people obviously but
you know recognize that at least that's
the first step recognize and a lot of
people do now but like conservatives
will never recognize that and they'll
never consider that to be
uh you know a slight against america or
anti-american activity because they are
the real americans or is tucker carlson
what does he call them they are the
legacy americans he said that yeah yeah
that's his new that's his new way of
legacy america is it wouldn't legacy
americans be native americans no he
can't say they're native americans so
they all he says legacy americans
yeah
that freaks me out so psychotic that
laughter is so scary
it's the last thing here yeah let's see
what this great conversation is between
these breaks for what they've been
saying and the actions they've been
taking yes ilhan omar doesn't deserve
committees by the way is he a picture of
health or what yeah
that's why i called him the toxic my man
just looks like the human embodiment of
goiter
this this is you on uh white nationalism
yeah this is what it says to you man you
just look like
you fix that okay sorry i'm ugly shaming
body shaming but like well he's an evil
[ __ ] so it's funny yeah
but for what they've been saying and the
actions they've been taking yes ilhan
omar doesn't deserve committees she
absolutely does not have another photo
wait wasn't she the one that was
uh removed from all committees
psycho yeah so okay so she's mad about
that yeah but hey don't worry she went
she went to the holocaust
she went to the holocaust museum and was
like i learned and then had to write
like a [ __ ]
had to write like an essay like a little
little uh a child okay that that did a
bad thing and was like i learned that
these comparisons are wrong she compared
uh people who don't want to get
vaccinated or wear masks to
jews during the holocaust yep which is
very apt obviously yeah a totally valid
comparison as a jewish man those things
offend me but i wish people had the same
passion for
the disgusting um islamophobia as they
do as anti-semitism i mean obviously the
i guess the difference being that the
holocaust is a tangible
uh remember uh somewhat recent reminder
of what anti-semitism can do and we're
still engaging in the process of like
you know doing horrifying [ __ ] to
muslims in the muslim world so that's
why so we haven't had time to reflect
yeah yeah once we're done with it maybe
we can look back and be like oopsie
sorry which probably won't happen but
you know
that's in the future yeah pro yeah it
may not ever happen actually
they've been saying the actions they've
been taking yes ilhan omar doesn't
deserve committees she absolutely you're
not even honest
she is on the foreign affairs committee
why is that woman on the because the
democratic party has her back that's why
oh they have her back they have her back
in the two apparatuses they have their
back and the democratic party the
republican party here has no time for
the trump
so hard the democratic establishment
that uh when she talked about uh aipac's
uh
like
clear influence uh in the form of dollar
values over uh congressional
representatives and like influence
beyond the scope of that as well uh they
were like this is anti-semitic how dare
you like it's ridiculous to say that it
is absolutely preposterous and
ridiculous to say that it is
anti-semitic to claim that aipac has
influence over legislation in a country
where bds boycott divestment and
sanctions
uh as a movement
is literally
uh denied in like 30 different red 30
different uh
states
like it is the most like
encroaching
most aggressive anti-free speech
legislation so much so that like even
dianne feinstein who's like 700 years
old was against it right like these
anti-bds legislations that they write in
like texas and stuff where if you're a
school teacher you literally have to
literally you live to sign a document
that says you will never be and have
never been in support of boycott
investment and sanctions
um
to be a school teacher
in the state of texas the free speech
state and it's [ __ ] remarkable to
claim that like the democrats are also
on ilanomar's side and like defend her
when they are the first to like
literally step up and threaten committee
uh removals whenever [ __ ] like any time
the democrats lose an election it's
immediately progressive's fault yeah
even though the truth is if it was a
progressive running
they probably would have won in my
opinion it's way more popular than these
milk toast [ __ ]
if a progressive ran and msnbc gave them
earned media in the same exact way or
msnbc cnn gave them the same kind of
positive coverage that they offer like
psycho establishment democrats then yes
they would 100 win elections and they
would be really good challengers to like
even republicans in purple areas but
that never happens the media in unison
and that's why i love the chris cuomo
and liz smith's story the media in
unison with political operatives that
work for establishment democrats will
always toe the line
and defend the pre-established hierarchy
and will absolutely do everything they
can to [ __ ] say oh are you
progressive you're anti-semite you're
racist you're anti-cop and we're pro cop
here
all this all this [ __ ] and even from
liberal outlets okay
even from liberal mainstream media
outlets that are more like center or
more center left they absolutely use all
of that and throw the kitchen sink and
progressive candidates and and totally
poison their uh their their approval
ratings yeah you know uh
i don't know if you watch attack on
titan but the new season's coming out
soon
there's a little preview here of it oh
god
she really is though she looks like
she's crazy
she's the uh have you ever seen her
smile when she is a big smile it looks
something like this
yes
she looks straight up like a titan i
have that one tweet
when i have a shot by tire it's just 100
um in the united states congress and
that and what she says is so that she
can represent radical islam
in the united states congress what about
her as radical islam you're such a
psycho [ __ ] yeah radical islam and
that's why she's uh for for trans rights
for example yeah radical the radical
islamists that you know
abortion you know it's funny and ironic
what margaret and taylor are my marger
margarine titan green
is closer to
uh radical islam yeah an ilhan is yeah
they have way more in common because
they're fundamentalists yeah that's the
whole point fundamentalist like wahhabis
extremists in greatest hit obviously
worth bringing up
she literally is that titan yeah
it's crazy yeah they have her in the
anime actually lore wise this is
encouraging because it proves that you
can there is
once you turn into a titan this proves
there is an antidote so that's that's
actually good news
spoiler alert the [ __ ] dude how do i
spoil it i'm just making a joke
that's not a real spoiler
[Laughter]
i just wanted to say spoiler alert
people will give me that idea
now you now you admitted that there is
no antidote double spoiler reverse
spoiler
um so
we are um we are out of time well that's
perfect because we're basically done
there you go
that was fun
yep
what do you think about like ultra
wealthy elites uh using the uh court
system to silence criticism
it's it's unacceptable it's disastrous
one of the things that like i do love
about america is a level of free speech
that you get for
dissent like the level of broad coverage
you get and protection you get for
dissent
um it's hard to [ __ ] make a
defamation lawsuit stick in this country
in comparison like the uk and stuff
so god bless for that yeah but you still
it's still very expensive yes and then
you financially buy for a regular person
if they were to get sued by someone
let's say like ryan cavanaugh they would
fold immediately yeah and that's the
point they they definitely bully people
with arbitration
uh regularly and uh so you're against
you are corporations do it against their
employees all the time
i am
yeah i'm definitely against like abusing
that court system
100 thank you and yeah people like ryan
cavanaugh totally do that thank you um
but you know what are you going to do if
you're
if you're running around looking like
harvey weinstein it's like
it's going to be they're going to make
that obvious comparison yeah
people yeah that sliding scale sold me i
like that's what i'm saying
so guys if you want to get more info on
that
go to google and type ryan kavanagh you
know and then go to the search results
look for the website this is important
to follow these instructions because if
you type it in into the search bar you
might spell it wrong click the website
spend some time studying familiarizing
yourself with everything
play this game
unfucked harvey weinstein you know what
i mean like harvey weinstein has like
you know what it is what ryan probably
doesn't have a mangled genitals and so
he didn't turn we don't know that ethan
yeah i said probably yeah yeah but i'm
saying like this is you when you have
deformed genitals and this is you when
your genitals are normal i'm saying he's
just
he's not essaying people ryan as far as
i know yeah so he's like
but i'm just talking about appearance
anyway not indeed
yeah that's what this website's all
about it's in the title familiarize
yourself with the content spend some
time on the website the kissing thing is
really straight what like why is he oh
we should add his tweet to the website
love you got that
i'm on it let's [ __ ] add his
his uh
tweet and supportive weinstein to the
website yeah that's his play the game
yeah he used to work with um mnuchin
used to be on the board of
of uh relativity
that's not surprising and
you know he's in good with the trumps
he got the trumps to do their trailer
thing yeah he commented yeah trump
commented on a yeah a trailer fight yeah
check out the website this is does ryan
cavanaugh look like on 9 11
was it apparently yes it was are you
[ __ ] serious that was how uh it was
the it was the 20th anniversary wait
where how did you know that where does
it say that right oh trump thing oh yeah
you said brian dm oh oh oh oh oh the
full live in person
what a great way to honor our uh
well you know trump has talked about 9
11 in the past like yeah you know very
bad but also i like power is the long
biggest now i like people who don't die
in terrorist attacks okay
he didn't say that but he he did he did
flex about i like i like the people who
got out in time
he was like 9 11 bad but also silver
lining trump tower is now the largest
tower say that unfortunately [ __ ]
insane yeah he's a positive guy silver
linings all over the place yeah he finds
he finds the good
in everything
what a great episode thank you guys for
watching thank you to hassan yeah this
was fun i i had a great time it was a
good one eh we learned lots of fun we
saw liverpool we learned zac is lying
about his height lauren bobert's
husband's penis harvey weinstein's penis
yeah we know
that you know ryan cavanaugh looks like
a body double for harvey weinstein
yeah i wonder if his penis is mangled
that's it i would like to i would like
to know but who knows well maybe if the
if the lawsuit goes far enough we can
get on discovery pictures of his penis
jesus compel him to send us pictures of
his dick
i do not i'm sorry order please don't
sue me
yeah he's coming for you i don't know
no no no definitely not all right thank
you guys he's gonna force me to do
triller boxing fights now
he's gonna he's gonna force you to fight
jake paul yeah
that's gonna be an exciting one trump
will commentate it though hopefully
would that be sick
this is zane pecker
all right guys thanks for watching
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you